Senator Lindsey Graham senator thank you
always good to have you with us tonight
so you heard what the president said
today he talked about Easter wanted to
get these things open he said we have to
go back much sooner than people thought
do you agree well I think hopefully
we're gonna do it before Easter but it's
got to be conditions-based I want to get
out of Afghanistan but if the generals
tell me we'll get attacked if we get out
too soon I won't get out to the
president you're right to want to
jumpstart the economy but don't try to
create an economic bump that leads to a
spike in the virus our goal is to
destroy the virus so any decision to
open up the economy based on age or
region needs to be scientifically
blessed by the experts any president who
turns down sound advice journal war
usually regrets it so my goal is to turn
on the economy but it's got to be
conditions-based if the data supports it
I'm for it if it doesn't I'm against it
and I'll just say this if most Americans
heard from dr. blix and dr. pouchy that
it was not safe to go back to work no
matter what the president said most
would not go back to work yeah despite
what a lot of people are saying doctor
foul she went out of his way several
times today to say that the President
does listen to his advice does and that
he felt that that he felt that it was
divisive to suggest that you know to try
to pit them against each other doesn't
really help anybody in this country but
do you feel confident you know the
president while you talked to him a lot
that he will listen to their advice on
this yeah I'm very confident he will
because this president has the best
medical team around him the vice
president's done a wonderful job and
you're right mr. president to want to
turn back on the economy but we got to
do it smartly and here's what I would
suggest doctor pouchy said based on the
data they may be regions that we can
open up there may be demographics
younger people may be able to go back to
work without a lot of risk but I would
make my decisions based on my medical
experts the goal is to open up there
economy but it needs to be conditioned
space the number one decision the
president made smartly was to stop
travel from China early on only God
knows how many people are alive today
because he stopped travel from China
don't undercut that decision by wanting
to open up the economy too quick it's
got to be based on sound science yeah
all right let's turn to the bill on
Capitol Hill the Senate bill tonight
how does where does it stand is it the
right bill I know obviously there's a
lot of push to get it done but it needs
to be something that is effective and
you know what what are the problems
right now as you see it for tonight
well it doesn't need to be that green
new deal this bill had a bunch of junk
in it that was just a liberal wish list
I think most of its out Mitch McConnell
said we're inside the two yard line but
here's the problem there are 20 people
playing defense they're all kind of
special interest groups trying to get a
little bit more trying to say no to this
no to that here's what I say if we don't
have a bill in the next 48 hours every
member and every staff person up here
should lose their pay and their benefits
until we pass a bill martha mcsalley has
legislation to do that if we don't have
a bill in the next 48 hours I'm going to
go to the floor of the Senate and make a
unanimous consent request to cut our pay
and benefits off until we pass one I am
hopeful but I've been hopeful for the
last 48 hours passed the damn bill
people are out of work they need a
paycheck the doctors and nurses are
under siege they need medical supplies
small business has been put out of
business let's put them back in business
enough already passed the damn bill so I
mean do you think what do you think is
reasonable in terms of a time line or
when are we gonna see this vote and the
house is an obsession and that that's
okay so Chen you you believe the bill
will pass tonight in the Senate if it
doesn't pass tonight there's no good
reason there is no good reason left to
deny the American people the relief they
need every restaurant and bar in South
Carolina is closed as long as you can't
congregate with ten people are more the
entire economy shut down so people need
a paycheck
they need to have burdens taken off them
their student loan payment deferred
there's so many good things in this bill
there's two trillion dollars it is very
generous and what's holding this bill
love is special interest politics and if
in the next 48 hours we do not pass this
bill everybody in the country should cut
off our pay well I'm sure there's a lot
of folks that would have no no problem
with that and do want to see a
resolution here that that's the best
thing for it for the American people I'm
Senator Romney's and Quarantine a number
of senators are in quarantine should
should members of the House and the
Senate be able to vote given these
extreme circumstances remotely yeah
we're in a war we're in a two-front war
we're in a war war against a virus and
here's what I would say watch what's
happening in New York do you want that
movie to come to your neighborhood I'm
all for trying to jumpstart the economy
and turn it back on where it makes sense
but what happened what's happening in
New York could come to South Carolina
any other place if we really don't watch
it here so here's my hope is that we can
pass this bill which will put money in
the economy by time take fear and
burdens off people and we can focus on
killing the virus we're at war with this
fire some want to starve it I want to
bomb it and I want to kill it you starve
it by having social distancing - all
those people are not following the
guidelines shame on you you bomb it by
having therapies that will make it less
lethal and you kill it with a vaccine
when will we turn the corner when there
are less infections therapies that
really work not just talked about on TV
and a vaccines on the horizon that's
when you will have turn the corner
senator thank you